hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the course of his unfinished work the
posses Blaise Pascal has a long passage
discussing the infinite or rather to
infinite and how we human beings who can
conceive of the infinitely great and the
infant essa Mele small how we fit into
that picture and what its implications
are for our capacities to know the world
and understand ourselves he positions us
between the infinitely large what we
typically understand as the infinite or
infinity and there he's thinking about
it not just in terms of some sort of
mathematical concept but also the
universe and its vastness itself we'll
come to that in a moment and then he you
might say wavers back and forth between
the infant essa moldy infinitely small
and nothing nay aunt oh yeah
in in French so he tells us that we
should reflect upon our ourselves and
understand where we fit in so he says
let us contemplate the whole of nature
in her full and grand majesty and turn
our vision away from the low objects
which surround us so what is he talking
about there you know there were a lot of
not just mathematical and and geometric
Hall but also astronomical and physical
advances being made in Pascal's time
some of them by way of experiment some
of them by way of observation
some of them merely by theorizing some
of those theories would turn out to be
true some of them would turn out to be
false later but a picture was now
arising in which we human beings in the
world that we inhabit is not at the
center of the universe rather we're just
one small bit of it
we're inhabited one planet and there may
be a multitude of other worlds in the
universe so he says let us let him gaze
on that brilliant light set like an
eternal lamp to illuminate the universe
let the earth appear to him a point in
comparison with the vast circle
described by the Sun this is still a
heliocentric model but even this can
give us that that sense right let him
wonder that the fact that this vast
circle is itself but a very fine point
in comparison with that of the Stars and
we can go on and on and on he says the
whole visible world everything that
we're seeing everything that we inhabit
this planet that we live upon that we
think of is so incredibly vast almost
infinite ourselves he says is only an
imperceptible atom in the ample bosom of
nature then he tells us no idea
approaches it we may enlarge our
conceptions beyond all imaginable space
we only produce atoms in comparison with
the reality of things our capacity to
imagine what the universe must be like
or could be like is rather weak and
limited by comparison to what the
universe does in fact turn out to be
like and here he uses this very
interesting phrase that many people have
picked up on it is an infinite sphere
the center of which is everywhere the
circumference nowhere so how do we turn
out once we start engaging in this view
from above or from elsewhere that tries
to take in the totality of the universe
we wind up becoming almost not even like
ants but fleas are mites on ants you
know fleas are actually pretty good size
compared to ants now that you think
about it but we become something that
almost doesn't exist that almost doesn't
matter within this vast universe so he
says returning to himself let man
consider what he is in comparison with
all existence
regard himself as lost in this remote
corner of nature from the little cell in
which he finds himself lodged I mean the
universe
let him estimate at their true value all
the things that we get so obsessed about
not only ourselves he says but also the
earth itself kingdoms cities what is a
human being he asks in the face of the
infinite so that's a troubling thought
already but it gets even more so by
bringing in the other side he says let
him might a tiny tiny little arthropod
be given him with its minut body and
parts incomparably more minut limbs with
their joints veins and the limbs blood
in the veins humors in the blood drops
in the humors vapors and the drops
dividing these last things again let him
exhaust his powers of conception let the
last object at which he can arrive be
now that of our discourse and here he
says listen some people think that there
is in fact a smallest point in nature
you know we have the these Adamas there
was a revival of this in the modern age
under you know for example Pierre
Gassendi and they thought that you could
get to a smallest bit of matter when
Pascal says I see within that even a new
abyss I will paint for him not only the
visible universe but all that he can
conceive of nature's immensity in the
womb of this abridged atom let him see
an infinity of universes each of which
has its firmament its planets its earth
in the same proportion as in the visible
world in each earth animals and in the
last mites in which he will find again
all the firt that the first had finding
still in these others he goes on and on
now this is purely speculative
and this doesn't turn out to be the way
that nature does work once we you know
start using electron microscopes or
whatever it is that
you know 100 years certain how we're
gonna have that goes even deeper but it
turns out that the infinitely small
reveals an entire cosmos a world to us
at each point and he goes on and he says
that what is the human being in nature
now it depends on which perspective we
adopt he says by comparison to the
infinitely large we are a nothing we
barely exist at all by comparison to the
infinitely small we are a world a cosmos
you might pause to think for yourself
about your own body and what we know of
it at present that you are an entire
assemblage very complex ly organized of
all sorts of systems which are
themselves comprised of cells which are
in communication and circulation with
each other in a myriad of different ways
but it goes even further we now know for
example that you are not just those
organized systems of your own cells that
came from say your own DNA and processes
of reproduction you're also colonies of
bacteria which can die off and be
replaced by other bacteria they exist
all over your skin within your gut you
are in fact to use you know Walt
Whitman's famous phrase multitudes so
which of these perspectives is correct
that's where it gets quite interesting
both of them are correct both of them
tell us what we are and when we try to
sort of intersect them together it's
almost dizzying so he tells us we are in
nothing in comparison with the infinite
and all in comparison with the nothing a
mean we are a middle place between
nothing and everything and here's where
the upshot comes in since we are
infinitely removed from comprehending
the extremes we can't understand the
infant s amol we can't understand the
infinite in terms of the physical
universe we can we can imagine it but we
can't comprehend it he says the end of
things in the beginning are hopelessly
hidden from him in an impenetrable
secret were equally incapable of seeing
that nothing from which we were made and
the infinite in which we are swallowed
up so there's a sort of sceptical
conclusion coming from this and Pascal
goes on and says this is why we have
gone wrong in trying to understand
nature he says through failure to come
to contemplate not just to comprehend
which were not actually capable of but
just to contemplate to take into account
these infinities men have rashly rushed
into the examination of nature as if
they bore some proportion to her we
anthropomorphize nature and thereby get
it wrong so he goes on and he tells us
that all of the sciences are infinite in
the extent of their researches so it's
not just the physical world but also
when it comes down to it the world of
the mind the mental world the world of
the Spirit he says who doubts that
geometry has an infinite infinity of
problems to solve
there are also infinite in the multitude
and finest of their premises those which
are put forward as ultimate or not
actually self-supporting them based on
others which having others for their
support do not admit of finality but we
represent some as ultimate for a reason
in the same way as in regard to material
objects we call that indivisible point
beyond which our senses can no longer
perceive anything though by its nature
it is infinitely divisible so what is he
telling us about our own scientific
endeavors our ways of understanding not
just the universe but our place in it
and how we in fact make sense of it and
approach it even when we turn to those
things we are positioned between these
two infinities we don't even know our
own subject matters that are our own
activities thoroughly at each end so he
goes on and he says we naturally believe
ourselves far more capable of reaching
the center of things than embracing
their circumference but we need no less
capacity for attaining the nothing than
the all infinite capacity which we don't
possess of course is required for both
and he says it seems that whoever shall
have understood the ultimate principles
of being might also attain to the
knowledge of the infinite the one
depends upon the other and they each
lead to each other so what is the upshot
going to be of this doctrine of the two
infinities for somebody like Pascal he
says that we are something we are not
everything the nature of our existence
hides from us the knowledge of first
beginnings which are born of the nothing
the littleness of our being conceals
from us the sight of the infinite the
infinitely great so he tells us that we
are limited in every way we can
understand the things that are
in-between much better than we can the
great or the small we only understand
the things that fit our frame so he
gives us a lot of examples here too much
sound defens us too much light dazzles
us too much distance hinders our view
first principles here's where something
very interesting are two self-evident
for us he says in short extremes are for
us as if they were not and we are not
within our their notice they escape us
or we them and he tells us this is what
makes us incapable of certain knowledge
but it also makes us incapable of
absolute ignorance so we are positioned
not only between the nothing and the
everything the infinitely small and the
infinitely great we are also positioned
between complete ignorance and absolute
knowledge and that is the best that we
can
so notice we can talk about these two
infinite sui can extend our imagination
to them we can in fact contemplate them
and Paschal is suggesting that we ought
to do that but we will never be able in
his view to comprehend them
you